We met Erica.
I'd like you to meet her too.
Roll the tape.
Hi, Drew.
My name is Erica.
I am a mom of two and I work at home full-time.
I am on video calls all day,
and there's one thing that I constantly notice.
And it's my eye area.
My brows are really thin from years and years of plucking
and I can't find a way to fill them without looking fake.
My eyelashes are really light,
and no matter what type of mascara
or lash product that I do use,
it seems like they always just kind of blend in.
My hair is very fine and straight
and I use all sorts of products
to try to get a little bit of wave
or a little bit of a body in there,
but nothing ever seems to hold.
Help, Drew, help.
(audience applauding)
I am here for you, Erica.
Hello!
Hi, hi, thank you.
I definitely need some help.
First of all, you're already beautiful.
Now let's play.
Oh thank you.
Thank you (indistinct).
It's true.
I've been excited to do this with you
and I've really thought a lot
about the products that we sent,
I personally curated them.
So I sent you some products that will give you,
hopefully, a little bit of a performance driven,
low maintenance routine with a high maintenance look.
All right, do you have your box?
I do, I have my box.
So cute.
Okay, let's open her up.
First,
what I would like you to do is pull out this.
This is Kiehl's Ultra Face Cream.
The reason I love this
is because I want a moisturizer,
a moisturizer that's gonna give me
a fresh, dewy, supple look,
but not move my makeup around.
That makes me mad.
This is fantastic.
It's also really good for your skin.
All right, so start with that.
Then I want you to find
your favorite foundation or concealer.
Then what I went ahead and did
is I picked out these two Pixi colors.
I love Pixi, it's just a fantastic brand,
and I even worked with one of their formulators
that they worked on that brand with our brand Flower Beauty.
And they're just,
they're really great and very affordable.
This is called the Endless Shade Stick,
but really what I like about it
is it's gonna give you kind of a smoky look,
but I gave you these really subtle colors.
And by the way, I promise you I like this
'cause you can even see,
I do the same effect on my own eyes,
Robin Fredriksz, who does my makeup.
It's just so easy to put on.
You smudge out the edges with your finger,
they're really pretty tones,
and very fool-proof to apply.
Then I'm gonna want you to take this Benefit,
by the way, isn't this the cutest little packaging?
it's the Benefit Roller Lash,
and I love Benefit.
I've been a big fan for as long as I can remember.
What I love about this is it's tiny, low maintenance,
and it has a rubber head.
Bristles or rubber make a big difference in application.
A good tip is to go across from the baseline.
I want you to get
as low as you possibly can to that eyeball,
without hurting yourself,
but you want to go low and lift.
And then, if you want to turn it around
and go in that way to continue to discover lashes, do it.
Can I ask a dumb question?
Yes, please!
Do you put the mascara on top of the lashes
or just underneath?
Definitely, you can if you like to.
But what you really want to do is
you want to go literally to almost the eyeball
without hurting yourself.
The whole point is you want to go and lift.
Lift, lift, lift, lift.
High maintenance without putting on lashes.
I love it.
Erica, your eyes look so beautiful.
Thank you, I love them.
All right, now, for your eyebrows,
this is a Flower Beauty product,
which is the company that I have.
It's called Fiber Fix.
The reason I love this
is because there's a little spoolie at the end.
It is hard to work with markers.
Even pencils can be difficult.
This I love because it's a spoolie.
So I want you to go in the eyebrows that you already have.
Don't go outside the lines,
just work with what you've got.
The really important key, I think,
to the color tone of brows
is to make sure that there's enough green
or warm tones in them.
Because natural hair has green or warm tones.
I love them.
They don't look too over-shaped either.
They just look natural.
I love that.
I love the color.
You look so gorgeous.
Okay, now quickly, speaking of Flower Beauty,
throw this product on.
I'm obsessed with this.
It's called Color Shift, it's a universal neutral color,
and it's just, it comes in a really fun squeezy tube
and I love the interaction with this.
Now I'm already wearing a lipstick,
but
it is,
do you know what I love about this?
It's a mood ring basically of lip glosses.
It's gonna respond to your natural pigment
and work accordingly.
So it's gonna look a little different on every person.
But what you want it to do
is just bring out your own natural, oh my gosh!
By the way-
I love it.
Do you see how see-through that is?
That is your own natural pigment that it's picking up.
That's why it's a mood ring.
I got some pigment.
Okay, Erica, you look stunning.
And at the end of the day,
when it's all said and done,
I can't tell you how important it is to wash it off
so that you can start the next day
with a clean, fresh palette.
So I got you the Milk Makeup matcha stick.
It's a fantastic cleanser,
Milk is one of my favorite beauty brands,
Zanna Roberts Rassi, who created it with her team,
is a friend of the show.
So you want to go,
and a stick is just a fun way to interact in a cleansing,
it's not boring.
And listen, those things psychologically count.
So you're gonna take it all off,
and guess what?
Throw a little moisturizer back on.
You're gonna come full circle with this, Erica.
I cannot tell you how beautiful you look.
And it looks like effort was put in,
which I think is a really nice compliment to people
when they see you on Zoom,
that you care enough to put in that effort.
But you don't look like
you're trying too hard at the same time.
You're in that perfect, pretty little middle.
This is perfect.
This is like a little bit of a makeup kit
I can keep in my desk drawer
and bring it out when I need it,
and I feel like it's so easy
and it just made such a difference
and I feel better about how I'm showing up.
And as a little last minute bonus,
Erica, I know you always want to do
a little something for your hair.
Now doing one's own hair can be really intimidating.
I have a really great Flower Hair Tool for you,
and you can go and it gives you a little bit of bend
because let's face it,
a little bit of bend around the face
makes a big difference.
I do it, it works.
Thank you so much,
I love my beauty box,
and thank you so much for sharing your tips with me.
I can't tell you how fun this was for me,
and seeing the results, meow.
Thank you, Erica.
(upbeat music)